[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour
christian jean etienne oui bonjour
berlin car oui bonjour et aux auditeurs
de vente une première
voilà alors vous êtes membre du comité
tigeot on a eu comme une petite erreur
vous n'êtes pas président de ce comité
mais membre vous allez nous expliquer
qu'il ya une direction collégiale pour
ainsi dire et vous êtes aussi par
ailleurs président on le rappelle du
comité devoir de mémoire
il en sera question aussi en deuxième
partie de cette interview
alors vous êtes venu nous parler d'un
jeu concours d'histoire c'est la
quatrième édition organisée précisément
par ce comité
si je me vois alors présenté nous
d'abord ce comité qui est composée
d'historiens et de passionnés d'histoire
de tous horizons il a été constitué en
2015 mais pourquoi tout à fait alors
effectivement je suis membre du comité
des gens me voient le comité de
randonnée moins de surprises en est
partenaire
donc c'est tout à fait naturel que je me
retrouve pour en parler a effectivement
le comité des gens me voient aînés en
2015 après sa disparition trop tôt pour
certains parce que il avant pour vous
parler de ce genre on a fait le show oui
et non il faut rendre hommage à ali
pierre-georges qui a eu l'idée de créer
ce comité pour justement restaurer la
mémoire le pigeon mais surtout faire
connaître une vielle histoire le donner
le goût de l'histoire surtout que c'est
un des voeux de tiges ou dans sa
démarche d'historien il avait toujours
pour mission de rendre accessible et
avait aussi pour mission de mettre en
valeur les faces cachées de l'histoire
comme la révolte des dsa du carbet il a
été primé par le prix frantz fanon avec
son bouquin sur des étages
louis des étages thiney de nos
politiques martiniquais
il a aussi travaillé dès son jeune âge
en tant qu'étudiant en faisant le
premier livre d'histoire martinique 1
chimie liberté créole avec ses amis de
la ligue 1 l'union des leviers
pollinisation et c'est un an vraiment
simple noble affable qui a effectivement
voulu investir souris fausse tum des
marolles la mer est encore à connaître
parce qu'il y avait aussi cette démarche
de fuir les importations de martinique
vers dominique et vers sainte lucie
puisque la en angleterre avait déjà
aboli l'abolition de cologna s'il
partait sans aucune connaissance de
navigation si fait que la mer est
devenue un cimetière marin qui soit
dîner avec nous avons maintenant voilà
donc pour un portrait est évidemment un
peu trop rapidement mais n'a pas
beaucoup de temps un peu rapidement
dressé concernant donc georges bernard
mauvois surnommé tijou professeur
d'histoire chercheur en histoire
militants politiques et syndicales né en
1949 est décédé en 2011 alors le comité
dit je me vois lui rend hommage hommage
notamment autour d'un jeu concours et
d'histoire gratuit alors on va expliquer
un peu les modalités mais là on en est à
la quatrième édition alors ce concours
ce jeu concours a été victime aussi de
la pandémie l'écho vie d'un bien qu vite
vous avez dû le reporter absolument la
quatrième édition avec pour thème la
matinée à roubaix organisation au
créativité et résistant et martiniquais
était prévue en 2020 à cause du conflit
n'a pas eu lieu au lard poti donc en
2021 c'est la quatrième édition des
croisades déjà la première c'était sur
le cannois la deuxième sur résistance
des esclaves les habitations la
troisième sur l'habitation sucrière est
aujourd'hui autant grobet alors on est
dans la ligne alors scandé on va parler
du thème mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que il ya un objectif que vous affichez
que vous a signé pour ainsi dire à ce
jeu-concours vis-à-vis d'eux
de la population le but c'est de
permettre au plus grand nombre lite vous
de s'interroger sur les événements qui
ont structuré notre société absolument
des amérindiens à nos jours donc
effectivement aujourd'hui ont la peau de
thèmes contemporains et enrobés encore
des survivants de cette époque qui ont
qui ont témoigné et on veut montrer aux
antilles que cette histoire est
fondamental pour mieux comprendre les
complexités la société mois et demi vous
voulez que les martiniquaises et les
martiniquais et celles et ceux qui
vivent ici s'approprie l'histoire de la
martinique
absolument et puis en même temps
utilisent cette histoire pour surmonter
leurs difficultés et la période atteint
roubaix le montre bien il ya eu des
réactions il ya eu d imagination il ya
eu des créativités ya eu la résistance
aussi face à l'équipe 2 du maréchal
robien envoyé par à pétain et il y a eu
vent de révolte comme celle du go le
tout est à balata qui a refusé de tirer
sur la foule alors rapidement parce que
les inscriptions sont closes vendredi 26
pour les scolaires et dimanche 28 pour
les adultes c'est dans quelques jours
bien sûr ces accords s'inscrivent tout
simplement en allant sur le site côté je
me vois un mot site etc
le milk au conti je me vois tous collés
à robin gmail.com un téléphone 06 96 39
60 27 pour pouvoir effectivement
concours alors on évite aujourd'hui les
adultes aussi à s'appliquer
on a à proposer des tous les adultes
candidats libres historiens ou pas
historien matin enfin dix ans groupe
jusqu'à 4 personnes
ça va faciliter les choses c'est un jeu
c'est un jeu concours alors voilà un
moyen alors expliquer alors c'est un jeu
concours en fait c'est un questionnaire
c'est ça oui attention chers kaki et
chaque candidat une bougie a très bien
fait sans publicité avec des gravures
d'époque des photographies des textes
c'est la bushido fait 114 pages d'entrée
- d'accéder à cette histoire
selon les catégories les élèves par
exemple de cm2 auront les questions
d'éducation
mais chaque instant est enrobé d'un
extrait du texte
il fallait simplement aux bébés à la
consigne chercher un lieu vous
comprendre pour chercher l'information
les élèves de 4e 3e auront non pas le
texte mais les pages
la question porte ou la page 13 à 24
cha cha complexifier un petit peu mais
les questions sont les réponses on dans
le texte
et puis les termine le second terminal
au tout tout tout le volume à eux de se
débrouiller pour chercher et dansant
capable et puis les adultes ils ont la
brochure comme ils l'ont eue dès leur
inscription ils ont le temps de se
l'approprier inscriptions sans frais ces
inscriptions gratuites très bien et puis
donc comme tout jeu concours il y aura
un jury qui va déterminer voilà à
l'école loges à classer 1er 2e et rides
et les scolaires travail dans leur
établissement
on est en contact avec l'adac on a un
quota cas que le guidera les adultes
vont composer dans des lieux qui leur
seront précisées aux robes et à la salle
des fêtes à chercher dans la salle par
municipale etc
et il ya un concours on va corriger
évidemment les enseignants qui sont dans
le comité vaut ce qu'ogier il ya un
classement et on va faire en sorte de le
compenser le plus grand nombre c'est
parra conso titre c'est pas la course a
comme à liège à la compass mais de la
simple clé usb au brochet en profite
pour un petit appel à nos donateurs allô
allô partenaires là encore le prétexte
et de l'eau donnée des bouquins
d'histoire dès jeudi soir pour
effectivement continue pareil dernière
question
christian saint etienne à propos de ce
jeu concours d'histoire si je me vois
donc on rappelle les dates de clôture
c'est vendredi et dimanche vendredi pour
les scolaires dimanche 28 pour les
adultes
il y avait un cycle de conférences qui
était prévu aussi pour accompagner ce
que vous le maintenez ou par nous avons
l'an dernier déjà fait toutes les
conférences étaient prévus oui il nous
reste moins rapidement
nous allons justement nous réunir samedi
prochain par le 27 mai lot pour devenir
quels sont les conférences
on a un film magnifique un dvd sur la
martinique en enrobé vu de l'intérieur
c'est magnifique on va au moins essayer
de reproduire conférence et à celle des
milliards 10 sur la dissidence où il
pose la problématique effectivement 2
du concept même de la dissidence qui
partait pour rejoindre effectivement les
forces vives du charles de gaulle
mais ceux qui partaient aussi touffu une
situation difficile on va et faire en
sorte mais après le jeu concours après
les épreuves
on va continuer le programme de
conférences toujours dans la démarche de
l'essuyer la population il reste deux à
trois minutes christian saint etienne on
va terminer avec vous alors en tant que
toujours membre du comité dit je me vois
mais aussi président du comité devoir de
mémoire
on sait que ce comité avait été mis en
place lors du cent cinquantenaire de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé d'affaires
quel regard vous portez sur les
événements qui se sont produits ici
depuis le 22 mai de l'an dernier le
déboulonnage de quelques statues et puis
encore ces événements qui se sont passés
dans la boutique d'une marque de rhum
célèbre bien connu ici voilà
et puis ce qu'il faut faire comment on
en sort finalement de 7
ce prolongement de quête d'identité
peut-être effectivement la question est
complexe je sais pas jouer assez de
temps pour développer tout ça je sais
évidemment celle des villes que vous et
pour cause les deux rôles mémoire et en
autant qu'on se préoccupe de ce qu'on
appelle l'espace mémorielle martiniquais
effectivement les seules traces de notre
histoire dans les habitations
on n'existe pas les week-ends aigle et
kazan aig
cela dit ceux qui ont construit ces
habitations ne soient pas figure de
guerre il ya un problème dans la mesure
où les monuments et l'espace urbain
actuel ne correspond pas à notre réalité
vous en adou vous même déjà manifestée
par exemple à fort de france il ya
quelques années tout à fait concernant
des détenus on a fait le succès puis la
rue la liberté ont invité des artistes
et politiques des syndicats et ça prend
la parole il y avait des ateliers de
dessin c'est en quelle année vous
souvenez c'était en 1997 à juge unique
face et aogo kb et on nous avait dit
vous louez personne est bien apprécié
multi fait les gens sont venus et on
avait donc endeuillé déjà joséphine deux
échassiers avec un voile blanc l'autre
avec un wallon avait avec endeuillé
joséphine on avait déjà vu qu'il fallait
faire un problème avec ça par contre
nous avons préféré joséphine coupé qui
est appelé le passant les étudiants les
élèves plus que de le dire
on a aussi une proposition de remplacer
l'espace de onu mans 2-2 des nordiques à
part un musée participer à cela avec la
ville de fort de france était opposée à
la gestion municipale special.t a mis en
place c'est pourquoi ils ont également
fait pour réveiller un projet qui date
déjà des années 80 où le comité de bâle
avait proposé un mur de la dignité avec
de nous des esclaves des habitations et
à l'occasion de notre participation à
cette commission
mais moi classe mission nous leur
proposons en lieu et place de la statue
de fait en somme ce musée avec des qr
codes qui vaut effectivement permettre
au visiteur d'en savoir davantage et
puis en face de la mer où effectivement
le col est arrivé mais aussi les bateaux
l'aiguillé où sont nos ancêtres et il ya
effectivement un point de vue magnifique
arrêt story l'histoire donc c'est en
instruction mais le projet parce que
c'est une bonne idée qui est accessible
qui est réalisable
le premier monument était déjà bien
parti on avait fait un concours
d'architectes mais n'a pas abouti
alors hop ovni en conclusion tout
monette et perturbe les supplie part
cela nous pensons que il y à une
impatience de ces personnes qui n'ont
pas tous assimilés de l'histoire ou
plutôt des conditions trop vite assimilé
alors ils sont impatients comme toul où
les jeunes dit vouloir révolutionner la
chose et il ya parfois des maladresses
j'en veux pour preuve un témoignage à
koungheul le hci vos collègues et maman
qui dit j'avais mon fils avantage à
faire à jm il ne peut pas le faire
quotidiennement est ce que les membres
de aux jeunes hommes peuvent le proposer
un sage
j'ai trouvé ça très émouvant
effectivement on peut pas casser pour
casser et alors il paraît que la
prochaine cible c'est la discipline et
sont alors je mets en garde ces
personnes la discipline et ça n'a rien à
voir avec la syrie ces registres coco
ailleurs ils sont nés en 1931 donc
effectivement la période était
d'ailleurs assez ils sont nés la fois
sans son attention ne pas faire de
confusion à l'agent a aussi dans
l'histoire
il a fondé les frères les sauts sont
effectivement fils de commerçants et
aujourd'hui madame j'oublie sont nos
gouvernants et son groupe il a fait
alors qu'elle était médecin et qu'elle a
le plus fait que la seule chose n'a rien
à voir
cavani d'où la nécessité de bien vous
font dire et ne ne pas faire une lecture
particulière de l'histoire avec une
grille de lecture qui ferait un
correspondant l'histoire avec les
objectifs et les bus de cette aile
personnes merci christian saint etienne
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
j'en journée merci beaucoup un échange
très intéressant autour de l'histoire de
notre histoire je vous rappelle le site
internet pour en savoir plus et et
remplir le bulletin d'inscription pour
le concours
si je me vois c'est qu'on coup anti-jo
mauvois points 1 tiret monsite.com et
puis le numéro de téléphone vous me
direz si je me trompe c'est le 06 96 39
60 27 exactement
merci beaucoup bertrand caruge belle
journée on se retrouve demain à 7h18
écouter sa voix si le son du jour c'est